wow wow it's really close
hourly rapid wins by one vote
I thought this was gonna win by more of
the chobava London Blitz
was really close I might take executive
decision because if I were to vote which
I
I uh I was a little bit too slow to vote
in my own poll I think I would have
voted for Joe Bava London Blitz
it makes for better YouTube content
sorry if
this makes me a dictator
but
I'm just imagining the Future YouTube
content
Joe Bravo London every game I recently
played Joe Bava London against Obama in
this Mr dodgy Invitational
I got absolutely crushed as white
it was a rough game but it was fun
so try and use my experiences
okay here we go
Joe London Blitz time
this is an open tournament it's free to
join
oh
oh we're starting with this position
that's cool I'm playing camel clutcher
okay let's see uh let's see how camel
does also let me fix this board
sorry about that should be better now
E4 okay so we're following this um oops
it's Hans game
uh takes
so there's takes in D5
um I'm gonna play this move Queen A5 and
then take
the main line is C3 takes Queen A4
I think it's Bishop D7
wait I'm trying to remember
Bishop D7 or Knight C6
I don't remember Queen D2 being the move
but we might see some uh Gambit style
from lights
so let me update the stream title
before I forget
um Also let's develop I have to watch
I've heard this move actually
I'm wondering if I can play
like E5
it's actually a really interesting line
I think go for this I'm calculating
takes and then this
okay I guess I'm maybe losing back the
pawn but I have this move
living on the edge
okay do I want to take
Rook B1 Queen A3
it's really risky
but
oh dear I just plundered a queen
I just plunger a queen I forgot about
rookie2 I was calculating Rook B1
okay who know my queen
camel beat me the last time we played
and the previous game I also blundered a
queen
but maybe there's chances for some
conversation here
oh this is also rated even though it's
thematic
oh no my reading
I Bishop D7 or Bishop E7 castling
he files very cluttered
foreign
I'd like to play some Rook d8
I get the chance
yeah that's a good move
can I start with Rook d8
realizing this is a very bad decision
although now I have Rook C8
I'm just trying to make things confusing
got some time scramble
maybe a five
like almost trapping the knights
Knight has this square but then
um
this is escape
I can take on E3
oh the pawn was just hanging
if I have this move
now this move
threading The Rook
okay
might be winning back
something here
Queen and Knight are hanging
while the game to start the tournament
threading this
I take that
oh it's so tricky
and there's Queen C6
complete this move
oh dear
[Music]
tactics
oh
wow I was very fortunate The Rook was
hanging there
I meet with two Bishops
wow okay
I wasn't gonna figure out the two Bishop
mace in uh in a second so
helped out the the pawn promote
okay
it reminds me to turn on my heart rate
monitor
oh dear good game's a camel
I was a fitting ending my blundered
queen was Reborn
to avenge
the tragedy
nice nice okay
so next game guaranteed to Obama London
a leader there's a few leaders and three
points
full Theory quack I was all yeah it was
a purely theoretical game
uh
okay so with E6 E3
and
I should know what I'm doing I think G4
is actually a common idea
now each word is also quite typical
but this is one of the cool things about
Joe Bava London you kind of break
principles
but you do so in
a very aggressive way
going for the quick King side attack
would you want to play G5
hinder blocks developments chase the
night away
going for H4
okay let's move follows principles I
think A3 is generally useful
controlling B4
wow
okay going for B4
I was more prepared to attack on the
king side so counseling greenside was I
think a wise decision from Black
but I still want to attack on the queen
side now
and maybe I'll go for group B1
a queen G3 first
I'm creating the battery
E5 is an idea
but there's a nice idea to meet E5 with
so let's continue
[Music]
it might be a slow move
but the point is after E5 which looks
very strong I can take
okay it's not quite happening though
let's play Rook B3 defending
and the point is takes takes takes takes
and then Bishop G5
uh winning some material
oh actually E5 hangs D5 too
yeah that definitely wasn't happening
hmm
okay I guess H5
I might end up castling
I give G6 I Castle
and the king is actually very safe
although I just blundered a fork
we both missed it
and now yeah it's funny I I said D5 was
hanging in the copulation earlier
but uh it's a very key Pawn now the
Queen's attacked and the Knights hanging
Queen f8 is probably the best
but I'm essentially winning a couple
Pawns
B5 here
I want to open the file
black doesn't want to open the file
okay so maybe queen queen G2
getting out of the PIN
this could be a useful diagonal
take with Pawn
there there's some pressure
I think this move
does a nice job neutralizing
I might lose that four but should be
okay
I have Queen F4 I take on A5
I'm threatening made in one
I don't want to trade Queens but yeah
maybe I have to
I could play F3
F3 first
and then four
okay expanding
things earlier to out my life
appreciate the first time Prime
I'm a little bit stuck here actually
like how to make progress
it feels like some kind of zugs one
if I play this there's Knight D5
but I might have to go for that
eventually
okay here I can take
this first
losing F4
some idea to take
start with King G2
that's a funny line so it takes and then
here
there's not a four but then King and
King G3
I'm queening or winning the Knight
so maybe it wasn't the cleanest
conversion but
my second game in a row promoting
a very late stage
I'm not scared of discoveries light
moves anywhere it's Chuck but I also win
the pawn
okay
no mercy
where's my mate
okay that's a nice mate
I took two queens of that game to finish
things
Gigi
so for everyone just joining this is a
thematic tournament
it's the report Joe Bava system usually
called jobava London but report is a
another grand master that helped me make
this opening very popular
let me visit let's play C5
C5 is my go-to propagances
wow Bishop E5
not the move I've seen before
but okay I'm just gonna follow
principles here
trapping the bishop
I'm realizing light could have taken and
won the pawn
I may have fallen for some like funny
trap there if I played correctly
thank you Noble marks
I got this bishop uh generally in the
opening Bishops should not be smack in
the center
because they can be easy to exploit
okay continuing with some aggression D4
takes I'll take with knights
oh there's a funny line it involves a
queen sack too
so Knight D4 Queen D4
oh the funny line actually wouldn't work
I'm just realizing
maybe this move first
yeah a lot of funny lines here
so I can take on A2
there's also this move
play this move
it's a fork I want to remove the
defender and then
get to the king
probably see this we might see Queenie
one
yeah C2 is falling if takes I'd probably
take your first
ooh
I'm spoiled for choices
all right let's take there
so neither Knight can be taken C Pawn is
pinned
let's take here
yeah there's some some force made I
think it's me next move
King B1 Queen D3 checkmates
okay that was a nice game
yeah Bishop E5 generally not recommended
although
I mean if white took and then took here
I would have been down a pawn for
probably almost no compensation
I probably had to play like E6
and something like C6
and some fun games so far
I was the first berserk win
got about 40 minutes to go
yeah C5 is going to be my go-to move
I guess for anyone that wants to like
make a repertoire against Obama London
this is a line I recommend and then
Bishop G4
it's a bit offbeat
but um
it's nice and simple following
principles
I think uh yeah I'll go for E6 and
Bishop D6
don't mind taking
this is a bit more positional
Castle
ooh
yeah that didn't really help white now
this move is possible
Queen scene one
let's go for it it's a fancy move having
some fun there's a rook be one I take
and take if Queen C1 I'm thinking about
taking
and then we trade queens and I'll be
able to use the C file
and then later try and exploit the
double Pawns
what is jobavam
so this jobava London opening It's a
combination of Knight C3 and Bishop F4
early on
but jobava is also a very strong
Grandmaster
from Georgia
he used to be over 2700
I think his ratings fluctuated a bit
over the years
I did recently play him in Abu Dhabi
back in August
he absolutely crushed me in like a
really brilliant game
one quickly with the black pieces
and in general he's a very uh very
creative player
there's a lot of cool opening ideas
wow why does one capture away from
Triple A Pawns
Triple A pawns are even more rare than
AAA batteries
I kind of want to play A5 A4
just for the lulls
um yeah let's start with this
I'll be disappointed if white plays A4
okay preparing this
[Music]
um
a rook F1 is pretty much forced
ooh
okay no mercy here
so I've cut the king off on both files
the king now has no legal moves
but I'm not quite threatening mates
actually now I'm finding Maiden two
yeah not playing A4 this game or G5 is
track meet GG
um
yeah at some point that just went
downhill
I think White had to play Queen C1 or
you're even Bishop C1
to deal with uh the pressure
all right wow camel culture leading
after losing the first game he was gone
on a complete Rampage
berserk winning the last three games
I'm playing camel clutcher but with
pieces River or colors reversed
okay let's see camel's crap with the
black pieces
92 reinforcing
go for A3
and maybe H4
and this is a main plan that I know in
jovava
is to
attacked ruthlessly on the king side
I should really know a bit more maybe F3
G4
my goal in this game is to not hang my
queen
let's see if I can accomplish the simple
goal
oh E5
it's probably a good move
take it
now I could Castle queenside looks a
little bit risky
there's also this move
looks a little bit simpler
pressuring the pawn expecting this move
wow D4
so I could Castle
I think I will Castle
which basically pins upon to the queen
so forms a d file battery
and there's also three attackers against
the pawn the only move to defend is
Knight C6
and also defends the queen so yeah we do
see an ic6
I have to take
and then perhaps 94
so it takes takes
this bishop really wants to develop
a line with the King
I'm fantasizing about Bishop C4 and
Knight G6
but let's start with Bishop E2
if it takes probably takes what night
because the pawn is weak now
no offense
yeah I think I'm winning a queen Pawn
um there is takes in Queen G5 but then
Rook D2 defends this Pawn
ah but then Rick dates
maybe Queen D2
I still have to be careful
there's some compensation I mean my
pawns are kind of scattered
in this open file
uh Queen D3
I'm realizing if Queen G5 I just played
this I'd be very happy to give away the
g-pawn
always play King B1
Queen D5
wouldn't mind trading Queens
hmm
good move
and queen B3
now I can play A4
but taking and actually let's play Four
I think it's a safer move Rook D5 may be
coming soon
hmm
thank you
it's not so simple
I want to win this Pawn
is very quickly turning into a bullet
game
going after B4
it's actually crazy it's going to be
probably three on three eventually
a box holding onto that pawn
start pushing
let's keep pushing
three Defenders three attackers
I want to play Rook B7
maybe A7
that's a good move
okay supporting the pawn from behind
[Music]
wow what an end game
take take let's gotta start pushing
don't hurt me
foreign
always come down to the final moments
three promotions towards Zen there
Gigi
I was not expecting that game to end
with three queens on the board
okay so it's not in first place but I've
I should win all the games
trying to catch up to this person
playing Herbert
opponent Biz ricking of Cal berserk back
oops I mean not pretty move
I'll go for this E4 line
yeah this is a
topical variation
Bishop E3
okay solid development
so the game with Hans he blundered some
Bishop C3 but that's not possible in
that position
um go for this
here Rook E8
or uh rookie one first
aligning with a queen
and I'm trying to create some kingside
attack so I need to take and take
I don't want to play Knight G5
the queen still defends
okay aligning with the King three
attackers
I could simplify
I might as well
The Outpost
foreign
took some work
got the job done got a nice position
from the opening there very solid
nice piece Harmony
okay that's still a Chase
top person keeps winning I might play
this oh no it's not showing the top game
that's strange
oh they've been berserking though
maybe I should start berserking
I'll take this more seriously
and take some more risks thank you
scaven Dobbins
okay gonna go for this sign
so there's a lot of moves like can play
yeah the main idea is to provoke
um
provoke F3
and now yeah these pawns are targets
sometimes an issue in jobava London is
why you can't play C3 so D4 is more
attackable
there's other ideas like Bishop E4
um
I didn't want to take on B2 allowing
Rook B1
okay going after D4
expecting Bishop E3
um
so maybe I can just retreat
and now this and this are attacked
allowing Rook B1
I made no Rook A2 didn't trap the queen
because Queen B6
now I have this move
okay I don't think white can effectively
defend the Knight
that was probably the best try
okay still down about a minute but up
material
push the palm
maybe E5
yeah I'm willingly walking into the PIN
the light's defendable
so if Queen E3 I have D4
Queen E2 there's Queen C5 hitting the
knight in King
there's actually a really cool idea
Knight F3
look at this move triple fork and
discovered attack after he takes I take
here
because the queen was overworked
and that one a little bit more material
and let's play this
trying to chase the queen away from
defending the Knight
uh let's play this move
I wanted to start with Queen D4
okay
trying to suffocate
for the twerk
what's a twerk
is it when you
probably when you Fork while twerking
also my time is a little bit low
but this Pawn is ready to run
it's not easy to stop and queen D4 Queen
F3
oh torque is triple Fork
aha
uh yeah oh no my queen but oh yes my
queen
and if Knight takes or his check
and I win a bishop
Bishop H3
in K9 G4
winning a knight guaranteed
oh maybe not guaranteed
seven seconds
oops
the bishop was hanging there
oops
oops
how I met with king and queen
okay
uh almost freaking out at the end there
and barely enough time so many games
this tournament have come down to
use time scramble situations
okay
oh sanak has fallen so here we go
another Joe Bava London I'm gonna play
A3 this time preventing
Bishop B4 and now I'll develop normally
um
yeah let's go for H4
it's a weird Pawn formation
uh Queen D3
maybe just Bishop D3
although F5 could be coming
allowing it
you have castling I'm very ready for the
Greek gift
page five coming
so it's still equal material but the
main advantage
a white house here is space
trying to expand in all directions
the king might be happy on G3
and Black's playing well for the rating
very much holding on
probably only slightly better here A4 is
a weakness
um but looks like I'm finally winning
some material
Pawn can't be defended
the king should have stayed towards the
center
controlling the only open file
B5 will be um
like the most interesting idea
to create that outside passer
black is still going for B5
should still be okay
seven
King B6 it's not super simple
I didn't fully calculate this
I got two pawns now I can safely take
and The Rook can't take either a pawn
without
allowing the other to Queen
threatening made in one
okay
a nice mating pattern
okay in first place for the first time
in the tournament I think
um let's see if I can hold on 17 minutes
left and some change
I've been gaining a little bit of
raining
yeah it is interesting how like these
thematic tournaments are rated
but I guess it's it's kind of still a
neutral opening
um
no berserking
I'll play C5
it does help that I'm like relatively
well prepared in these lines
uh I'll just go for this in Bishop D6
a little more positional line
oh
I got tricked
I think I got tricked wow
I got tricked
I mean I have Knight C3 or Knight C6
I don't think that works though
there's King f8 which I think I'll have
to play
wow
96
take
that's not pleasant
wow
I'm in a lot of trouble
I think I have to go for the
slime
still could be interesting
now the problem is I can't effectively
defend
I'm in a lot of trouble here
also burned a lot of time
yeah nice play I fell for some trap
there
I'm gonna go full attack mode on on the
king side
the H5 King G7
so I'm down the exchange in two Pawns
foreign
I'm currently watching through the 2022
Autumn Marathon video for the second
time wow for the second time
I hope you're doing well you're a true
hero
yeah the title of the video because
that's like a 12 hour video the title is
something like if you click on this
video You're a hero but if you watch it
two times through
it probably makes you a god
okay so this position oh that's a good
move I don't want to trade Queens I want
to uh use the files
stop trying to trade Queens with me
I mean Rook 8 is now an idea we might
see Queen B5 back
interesting
Bishop E7
your rookie is still probably coming
yeah despite White's material advantage
it's not easy to like simplify
hitting F2
probably this move
so the Queen's tie down to defending the
Knight
there's really not too many squares like
Queen A4 I play this queen goes back I
fork
oh I get the triple Fork the twerk
uh that's a fine movement of this move
obstructing the defense and essentially
securing the Knight or pinning the
Knights of the B2 Pawn
if A4 I take it oh then there's a normal
Fork
but then I take and pin
that's a funny line the pin is mightier
than the fork
is this a move takes takes
almost working
I'm smelling a tactic here I don't see
it though
I have to improve my sense of smell
interesting play this
A2 is a target
if A3 maybe I sack
actually if um it was just sack not
calculating
it just looks like it should be winning
it better be winning
uh check
Queen E3
oh I'd still stops a meat
this move
wow what was this
Free Pawn
what's happening
ig2 coming
a crazy position
wow
we got another game I feel like I missed
something there
I missed like Knight D2 check at the
moment
I play that eventually
it felt so close
not even close
or not even close
good timing there yeah Knight D2
probably is the best at least the
cleanest approach
um
I wouldn't be surprised if there's some
Force mates
no
okay I took the pawn a lot of ways to
win
okay Master tournaments
ooh
there's an FM on my tail
but they're playing a game oh they're
playing camel
10 minutes left
thank you the Earl of Sandwich
yeah most people have been playing E6 I
think we had one C5 game on A6 game
C6
also playable
think Bishop D3 I'm not mistaken
probably Queen takes E3
and I'll go for E4
it doesn't seem like my phone's prepared
yeah gradually want to prepare E4 maybe
F3 E4
although C5 might be coming
[Music]
start with castling
yeah I don't want to just trade like E4
takes takes takes a lot of things come
off
but now I'm going for E4 making things
spicy
so C4 the queen just moves
takes I take with Queen
there's Bishop C5 Queen D2 D4
then Knight A4
yeah I have 94 the um I think the pawn
is a bit weak although there's E5 in
that line
just kind of going into this
um Bishop G5
and Bishop B7 if I take take
that line Looks playable actually
and if takes Bishop G5 I didn't
calculate Knight E4
takes takes takes
takes Bishops should be seven
maybe bishop C7
and I'll win the pawn in the end
uh but there's night before it takes and
then takes on B2 or B1
second B7 it's a big trade but D4 is
weak in the end
I mean ideally okay we don't go into
that
but we go into this so there's takes
takes
I was gonna say ideally I wanted this uh
Bishop G5 Knight H5
but this is also nice
defending E5
and there's still ideas of knife F5 and
queen G5 and mating
I think I'll start with this
so I'm threatening Rook D4 but also I
mean the bigger threat is Queen
G5 probably
black would have 98
um
there's a really funny line and I want
to play it
I want to play C4 and be black into
ambassanting and losing the queen
it saw on papin
I'm just gonna play C4
oh no you have to amp a song that's the
only legal move right
because it's such an easy blind spot
because it's the only case where like
both pawns disappear from their rank in
one move
of course opponent doesn't do it
but that's okay
I can take
actually is there um
ah there's almost a funny mine
start by taking
trying to figure out how this works
thank you so I'm gonna have this so like
Queen B2 i t i played 97 King h8 I take
threatening mate King athletes I might
have E6
oh no my Rook oh no my knight
everything's hanging
I'm running mate
oh wow
honestly didn't see that move
thankfully I have this move oh there's a
really funny line takes takes takes
it looks like I lose material
but this is double check
it's such a rare tactic double check
abstracting the queen
you don't see that every day
now this game is filled with tactics
yeah that's like that's really rare I
think if I don't have Knight D7 I'm in
trouble
because of other discoveries there's
Queen takes off four
and I guess Knight H7 is just King
somewhere
but uh that's such a feel-good move
because the queen and Knight can't be
taken because it's double check
oh I got past okay I need to win this
final game
okay
you camel clutcher for berserking
I don't know this line
G4 G5
when endowed push Pawns
FM blink might pass me
it's crazy I haven't lost a game this
tournament but
I might
I might finish in seconds
I hope is to get one more game after
this
I like this position
[Music]
um
92
Indiana G3
this is my third time playing camel
clutcher
okay leaving tension
take that
got a cube of pieces here
probably want to take with Knight
although
interesting E4
which road to do
is king of wanna
King on G2
wow
there's huge cluster of pieces here
but the night the Knight is pinned
that's the most important attribute
but what's happening take their
let's take this then F6 and then I take
the Rook
camel has won my queen so many times
I take this
Knight's pinned
rook's defended by the Knight
Queen F3 is probably coming
can we have three Rook D7
just doubling up
this is defended oh
F7
not so simple
[Music]
don't hurt me
I think everything's covered
e2's cover the night so good Defender
very tricky
start by checking and then taking and
then taking this
this is not me because it takes Queen
where's my funny mate
ah no funny mate
almost so funny oh always play F3
checkmate okay no time to waste
hey hey
Uh Oh blank is still playing a game
blank's trying to win this game
before the tournament ends
if they do we'll be tied for first
and what a game
good game camel clutcher pairings or
Clues I don't get to play any more games
so let's watch this one
if blank wins that I don't know who wins
on tie breaks
because the berserk win counts as three
points and that would
that would give a score of 45.
oh okay that wasn't a threat
but this is terrifying for lack
go Edward
50 seconds left in the tournament
playing trying to use all their
resources
it's actually really fascinating
foreign
Rook is lifting
hi Eric hello I registered for the
u1100 in Charlotte oh that's awesome
chances I could pay you to get a photo
of me at the ball oh you don't have to
have your work hey
oh except
oh get a photo of you
I think I was expecting you to see a
photo with me
um I think I'll be bringing my camera
but again I wouldn't charge for that
uh just
introduce yourself to me at the
tournament and
yeah ask politely and I'll try and have
my camera on me so
um
yeah I'll definitely be around like most
of the tournaments uh there's different
scheduled events but then I'll have some
free time as well
so
oh the term is over term is over okay
it looks like White's gonna win this
game
but that doesn't really matter
for the tournament standings
there we go where is the confetti
there's a confetti
my Chrome extension confetti cannon
so I hope people enjoy this
apologies again for
being a dictator and overriding the poll
from earlier but I think it was worth it
had some really fun games
shout out to everyone watching in the
future on YouTube
if you're watching on YouTube let me
know if you want to see more of these
like thematic opening tournaments and
also let me know what types of openings
you'd like to see so I think it's cool
to see
a lot of games in a row in the same
opening also if you're watching on
YouTube or twitch don't forget to
subscribe it does help the channel
on YouTube subscribing is free
on Twitch
is usually paid unless you have Prime
then you can sub for free
thank you Jay slickman
hi I'm YouTube famous now oh yeah I'll
have to make sure not to cut out that
part for YouTube
say hi to Jay slickman